on a tendance à associer le vote
conservateur à l'ouest du pays mais il
est aussi très fort dans la grande
banlieue de toronto
j'étais rencontrer des jeunes qui
pensent que l'avenir passe par les idées
conservatrices
[Musique]
ces gens pensent qu'il ya vraiment une
place pour les programmes sociaux les
programmes de gouvernement mais il doit
vendre tes limites à ce puits doivent
afficher une situation curieuse et gens
parce que quand libéraux ou la ndp et en
pouvoir
c'est comme si je suis pour le choix des
femmes comme totalement mais je pense
pas qu'on doit pour c'est toute la
société des tendances avec nous
[Musique]
c'est un programme d'austérité si elle
interdit aussi que c'est ce qu'on fait
on est plus adroit que vous êtes inquiet
dac avec le logo c'est monsieur four n'a
pas dit que c'est que ça allait être
l'austérité mais si l'austérité mais
naquit le déficit en ontario c'est pire
que québec c'est sûr que la nouvelle
casse toi tu es une franco ontarienne
oui les conservateurs de fort ils ont
fait du mal aux franco-ontariens s'en
fiche
si c'est pas idéal a
et puis sinon j'aimerais que je pense
qu'ils ont changé pour ce avec ça et
puis ce qui fait qu nesc ce n'était pas
la meilleure chose à faire est que les x
comptant bien sont communauté qui est
très intime qui ont besoin de ça va
continuer au canada ces messieurs il
faut partir sourit pas parfait mais
qu'en pense qu il fait prouvé les bonnes
raisons nous avons tout vérifié
[Musique]